I mean I feel like the year started off
on a very Summer Night particularly we
just recently lost Lisa Marie Presley
well you know that was a sad sad loss
and when I had made my statement I had
said you know that I just wanted to send
our symphys to Priscilla because I can
only imagine you know that's her only
child was Elvis's only child but I knew
that he'd be waiting for her and I just
knew that you know I thought well you
know Elvis is there waiting for her and
we just all loved that family like
family and just wish them the best but
that was a sad sad loss but anyway
hopefully they're up there being happy
together and hopefully Priscilla will
find some peace through the love that we
all have for her and we're all with her
have you had the chance to talk to
Priscilla I have not okay she's been
overwhelmed with all this okay she knows
we're all with her Dolly Parton reacts
to the untimely death of Lisa Marie
Presley who died after suffering Cardiac
Arrest last week Dolly shared her
condolences on Instagram writing quote
Priscilla I know how sad you must be may
God comfort you at this time Elvis I
know how happy you must be to finally
have her home and to have her back with
you
usually love to listen to rock and roll
I mean that's just what you do and but
at that time Elvis was very hot and so
many of those great people I had a crush
on Elvis like every girl at the age did
Dolly came up in the music industry
around the same time as Lisa Marie's
father Elvis he even attempted to cover
one of her classic hits I Will Always
Love You
[Music]
love you
will always
love you
but rights issues got in the way Dolly
explained that 2021 interview with W
magazine the singer clarified quote I
had to keep that copyright in my pocket
these are my songs they're like my
children before admitting I wanted to
hear Elvis sing it and it broke my heart
I cried all night I love the business
and of business I don't mind fighting
for something I believe in
[Music]
thank you